Pennsylvania Pennsylvania yeah what are
you doing out there anything good
concert concert gotta I was just on my
way home okay all right just so you
don't have a body cam okay yeah
yeah you were where did you come from by
chance did you drive which way did you
come in though uh I pulled in this way
okay did you Happ hit a curb maybe not
that I felt okay yeah not that I felt
all right so someone called and they
said that you driving they you hadit a
curb and you were driving in here that's
why we're here so they said that you
were driving all over the place so
that's why I wanted to make sure
everything was all
right okay well no okay that's why I'm
just asking that's why that's why I just
no I just well it's possible because of
the flat tire but okay I was just
pulling in here okay do you have
anything to drink
tonight any alcohol I mean like hours
ago hours ago yeah okay all
right yeah I'm just trying to I got
you
all
right I've never changed the flat tire
before yeah I hear
you she needs a toe or you want a tow
truck I mean I have a spare here I think
okay if I just change this out it should
be okay all right why don't you leave
that for a second I just want to step
over here just just leave that for a
second you change it I just want to make
sure you're okay to drive that's all
okay all
right you said you drank a while ago you
said yeah probably about 4 hours ago 4
hours ago okay and the concert was in
Bethlehem Bethlehem okay and then what
time was what time was your last drink
like maybe 11:00 11:00 okay I'm just
going to T touch your eyes make sure
you're okay just just cuz we're here now
okay just do me a favor just stand with
your feet together and your arms to your
side like this okay
uh you wear glasses you have like you I
have contacts and I also have um I had a
head injury okay so my eyesight's a
little funky but so if I put something
in front of your face I have special
glasses to wear okay so if I put
something right in front of your face
you'd be able to see it though yeah yeah
okay all right oh do you see the tip of
my pen okay I want you to follow my pen
don't move your head at all just just
follow with your eyes do you understand
y
okay
I'm just going to go up okay
M all right do you want to uh are you
comfortable in those shoes if I had do
another another test okay all right just
use we're going to use this line on the
floor okay you can stand right here and
face me all right um I don't want you I
don't want you to do anything until I
tell you to begin okay um you walk
normally you have any problems with your
legs nothing like that right okay you
have no like you don't have
like I'm just going to go up
okay all right do you want to uh are you
comfortable in those shoes if I had to
do another another test okay all right
just use we're going to use this line on
the floor okay you can stand right here
and face me all right um I don't want
you I don't want you to do anything
until I tell you to begin okay um you
walk normally you have any problems with
your legs nothing like that right okay
you have no like you don't have like Ms
or like nothing like
that I'm going to explain everything I
just don't want you to do anything till
I tell you to begin okay okay all right
when I tell you to I Want You To on this
line I want you to put your left foot
with your right foot in front like this
okay with your right heel touching your
left toe just like I'm doing right now
you can go in that position I want you
to stay in this position till I tell you
to move or tell you to begin okay you
understand yeah okay and I want you to
put your arms at your side just keep
them at your side when I tell you to
begin I want you to take nine heel the
toe steps down that line okay um when
you get to your n when you get to your
nin step I want you to keep your front
foot on the line take a series of small
steps and take nine steps back okay I'm
going to demonstrate it for you okay I
don't like I said I don't want you to
move it's I'll demonstrate it for you so
you can see it okay it's look like this
1 2 3 like I said I took three you're
going to take nine okay yep on your n
step you're going to keep that front
foot on the line you're going to take a
series of small steps like this and
you're going to take nine Heel To Toe
steps back and count out loud in this
manner one two three like I said I took
three you're going to take nine okay yep
hold on hold on before you before you
begin I want you to keep your arms at
your side okay I want you to count out
loud walk heel to toe and don't stop the
test until you're done okay you
understand y all right you may again one
2 3
4 and then turn around
yep the vehicle is across from number
s awesome okay uh one more test okay I
want you to keep keep your arms at your
side and your feet together like this
okay um when I tell you to begin I don't
want you to start till I tell you to
begin same thing okay
um when I tell you to either lift your
right or your left leg whatever you
prefer whatever you're comfortable with
approximately 6 in off the ground it's
going to look like this okay and you're
going to count out loud in this manner
1001 1002 1003 1004 till I tell you to
stop okay um I want to keep you I want
you keep that foot parallel to the
ground and keep both legs straight the
entire time you understand yeah okay go
ahead
tet can sorry no you're
good that's fine all right um I'll guess
you again you had a little bit more than
just a few drinks I could I could tell
based off your eyes and your tests so I
know it was it was I don't know if it
was no I've with my contacts okay I have
special glasses I'm supposed to wear
okay what are the glasses what are they
for um because my
mhm it's all right take a deep breath
that's why I'm asking my vision um M I
had a head head injury that's what this
what kind of head injury I got headbutt
by my NE okay
um and it misaligned my eyes okay so do
do you have a certain do you have a
certain something with your eyes does
that does that happen what is it called
Uh there's no for it it's just a
misalignment with my okay with my eyes
but it causes the okay nagus dry eyes do
you have do you have something do you
ever called nagus is that something
that's you were ever told that you have
no okay but my eyes
don't anyway okay so like I said someone
was behind you and they saw you driving
all over the road and hit a curb so
that's that's that's why that's why here
it was like I said I didn't show up here
cuz you R curb I pull I was pulling over
because my tire the dam your car was
that was that what what about that
that's way old that's way old there's
actually a police report for that okay
uh the tractor okay so you're going to
Manville right yeah so um your car's not
drivable and right now to change your
tires pretty pretty crazy right I
mean
why is it crazy okay well I mean it's
3:00 a.m. I mean that's
why I have all the all
right want to test
yeah he's just going to test your eyes
okay that's
fine what
happened oh go
again what's your first name Daniel
Daniel I'm John okay nice to nice to
meet you I know my partner did your eyes
I'm going to do them also okay fine uh
this is just a a thing all right
um you're so you're not nearsighted
you're not farsighted um do you have
your if I don't have my contact do you
have your contacts yes I do so you can
see I can see okay when I ask you to
Daniel I'm going to ask you to please T
to take any finger when I ask you to
okay and touch the tip of my pen when
I'm holding it up here top the top when
I asked you to okay
okay all right could you go ahead and
touch that for me now
please okay Danielle what I'm going to
do is I'm going to make several passes
in front of your face with my pen okay I
would like you to follow my pen with
your eyes and your eyes only please do
not move your
head please do not move your head okay
okay do you understand yes okay here we
go you got to you got to watch it with
your eyes right so okay
see um when I'm moving the pen right
like I would like you to follow it so
like you want me to trace it with my
eyes yes exactly exactly don't just look
at me right I was I I got I got it I got
it so I want you to follow it with your
eyes right got it you ready yes
okay
[Music]
I I I got four mhm okay all right ma'am
do me a favor please turn around transer
back all right what why under rest for
okay what no no no no no no no no no
we're not going to do that wait why why
why why why why why I'm going to explain
everything to you okay relax okay I'm
calm okay stay calm J me favor relax I'm
going to explain everything to you in a
second I need know why so Bas I'm going
to explain it to you okay let me let me
let
me okay let let me tighten these so they
don't get tighter on your wrist okay I'm
not I'm not moving no I know but I'm
going to I'm going to explain everything
to you okay
no so we got a call from from our
dispatcher that was coming home from
work right and you were all over the
road and youit hear me out let me
explain myself okay and you hit a curve
okay that's why you have a flat tire
okay your eyes are horrible okay that's
my that is not let me put my glasses on
glass your glasses have nothing to do
with it they do though I'm telling you
right now they have nothing to do with
it okay handcuff so I'm going to hold
I'm going to hold on to you can I please
tell you something sure go ahead can I
please put my glasses on I promise you
makes a difference yes it does your
glasses have nothing to do with nagus
okay nagus is the involuntary movement
eyes when you're intoxicated and I smell
the alcohol coming from your breath I
smell it fine all right I'm just letting
you know why why we're here I'm not
making I'm not making this stuff up
child okay you're not going to lose your
child in New Jersey hear me out no I'm
going to lose my in New Jersey listen
Len listen I need my grandpa let me talk
in New Jersey DWI is not a criminal
offense listen no you're not it's not a
criminal offense you're going to come
back we're going to do paperwor listen
listen and you're going to get released
tonight you're going to get released in
an hour yes you are I'm telling you the
truth it's not you're going to get a
ticket that's all it is yes and then my
it's not a criminal offense it doesn't
matter I don't tell anybody nothing to
get told you get a CRI and you have to
go to court that's it that's what
happens okay there's nothing that says
that we are going to go and tell what's
going on here it's not a criminal
offense it's not it's not like you get
arrested for shop or anything like that
it's a ticket it's a traffic ticket okay
that's how it is in New Jersey I'm just
letting you know I have a job to do so
do officer so do officer Dober okay I
have to I have to I'm walking to the car
I have to I can't let you walk without
me holding
you can you UNC me please no I can't
uncuff
you do I have to call someone you're
going to we're going to call some as
soon as we get back and they're going to
come pick you up in about an hour all
right do you have anything on you cuz
you're you're female I'm not going to
startch you do you have anything on you
that's going to hurt me okay do you have
anything in the car that you need do you
have anything in the car that you need
do you have anything that's going to
poke me stick me nothing like that I
don't okay do you have do you have a do
you have a phone on you where's your
phone my phone's in my pocket okay where
is it in your pocket in your back pocket
yeah okay I'm going to hold it for you
so you don't lose it all right and I
want you to sit on it it's coming with
us it's coming with us okay you need a
de bre before can you please take these
cups off me cups aren't coming off they
have to stay on toay you got to take a
deep breath or else I'm going to call an
ambulance cuz you're typ of ventilating
okay take a deep breath I have anxiety
really hard do this okay take a deep
breath take a deep breath I'm telling
you you're going to be released tonight
and you're going to call someone as soon
as we get back you're going to call
someone as soon as we get back okay take
a seat okay take a deep breath and take
a seat what are you guys going to do
we're going back to headquarters I just
need you're coming back to headquarters
we have to do paperwork what happening
so we're going to come back to
headquarters okay I'm going to give you
the option to blow on the on the Alro
test machine okay if you don't it's
going to be a refusal I'll explain all
that St listen listen listen listen
listen you're going to get hear me out
you're going to get no no no I don't
want you to say anything I just want you
to listen okay I just want you to listen
you're going to go back you're going to
I'm going to give you the option of
blowing the Alro test machine once
that's done I'm going to let you call
your grandfather he's going to come pick
you up that's it I promise you that's it
I'm not lying to you okay everything's
recorded everything's on body cam uh
headquarters is right down the road okay
I know what all right okay all right
take a seat okay take a deep breath
relax I'm I'm telling you we
everything's on body cam I want you to
take a deep wrap all right take a
seat pocket is your is your pocketbook
in there so we we're going to take it
with us we're going to take it with us
so that way you have it take a seat
okay take a seat okay I'm going to leave
the window open I don't want to be in
the I understand slide over I know not
many people
do please uncuff me please I can't uncu
you okay that's the policy all right in
the back seat yep you're going to stay
right there all right John can you stay
with her real
quick what up do you need your house
keys or anything like that are they in
the car I'm going to get everything you
need right now so let me know what you
need what do you need in your car you
have house keys that's on your keys CL
my grand parents are picking me up okay
they're in the middle of console okay
Danielle can I I just Daniel can
I uh I did I think I did yes I did let
them know uh yes it is on the way please
Daniel can I explain something to you
please I don't know well hear me out for
a second okay take take a deep breath
number because this is going to be a
whole lot worse than what you think it
might be right if you're and hear me out
for a second it already feels well it
could if you get like all sick like if
you make yourself sick I'm okay I'm fine
that's all I'm concern I'm just I'm just
okay so here this is crazy here's what's
going to happen Okay um as officer Gro
said you're going to be given an
opportunity right to either take a
breath test or to not take a breath test
okay okay whether you take it or not
you're still going home okay we're still
going to call something rather yeah but
what is the he's going to read something
to you okay it's a very it's it's it's a
thing going to get red to you I'm going
to lose my k your your wallet and
whatnot is what you're going to need is
it in your car
yes
yes I'm going to lose my
kid
from could you please put me down for
body ter
failure
ke house are these what you're going to
need yeah but if my grandpa's picking me
out I'm going to bring them just in case
okay where's your wallet at it's in
there too it's in there what does it
look like it's a black okay
clutch the car keys are on the driver's
seat okay please take this off me Daniel
we can't it's
poliy it hurts no actually I could see
you moving your hands around and well
yeah no I can move them but all right
I'm just not used listen I'm not saying
that you're used to this right and I
don't I'm glad that you're not used to
this yeah but I'm going to lose
everything I'm going to lose my job I'm
going to lose my kids I'm going to lose
everything I
just it's
okay maybe maybe you won't no I will his
dad is abusive and crazy 63 Hill
15 thank
youn call for the call down
here I
need you need what party party wants to
be anonymous I want to call my dad
you're going you can't call him from
here but when we bring you inside you're
going to be able to make phone
calls so what's happening exactly you're
not going to jail tonight how's that but
I'm getting I'm getting I'm getting
charged with something yes you are we
driving while I'm
toxic I'm toxic wet or you have
something else yeah she can't get this
hand
out no I can't it's tight enough don't
worry is this is this your wallet yes
okay is your wall is my license in there
I don't know I don't know I I I couldn't
really find it
so yeah I know my car's trashed single
mom
life would it be somewhere else cuz I
don't see it in
here I probably took it out when I was
getting pulled over well you never got
pulled over you weren't
here when I saw you guys I probably took
it out
okay my car somewhere I don't know we're
going to bring
this I want to talk to my dad okay we're
going to let you call him as soon as as
soon as we get
back Daniel you own the
car um yeah it's under your name
yes I think the registration is due this
month okay
you could just defend that
deal can you respond down here pleas
I know
I are you an
operator someone from someone that lives
in Manvel come get you right I'm hoping
if they answer I if not we'll send
someone there to to twak them up no well
someone has to come get you so that's
the law so if if that's the case then
then we we'll get someone to come get
you
615 from
stand
by one of the surrounding agencies came
and just over the car for few
minutes can you just tell me exactly
what happens with all this I don't can I
know
three if you take whether you take the
breath test or not yeah you're still
going to be going home okay that's the
first thing you need to
understand doesn't matter my parents are
going to I'm going to be disowned it
doesn't matter just okay based upon
those results we'll determine what kind
of tickets you get okay okay and
um that that's it that's so say say I
refuse it I'm not going to but say I do
you have that right you just get another
another ticket you get another tiet get
an additional ticket additional ticket
from the DWI yeah so you will get dwr
and refusal right if you take the test
so if I take the test then I get you'll
get the read you'll get a reading
whatever that reading as well as the DWI
just the D you only would get the DWI
but if I refused it then I get the
refusal which is an additional to the
DWI ticket yes so whatever Court happens
int
so we can't give you advice on what to
do we can just let you we can just let
we just let you know I'm going to
there's a whole paper that I read to you
and then that will clarify things um
clarify things a little bit more for you
okay can I call my dad yeah soon as we
get back we're just waiting for another
person cuz we can't leave your car
that's just the way the law
is oh so I have to pay the
impound so so the reason pay impound so
the yeah so the reason why that is is
because someone years ago we left the
car and then they came back and drove
the car and then killed a marine so
that's why that's the law oh shit yeah
so that's why that became oh no okay I
mean I wasn't questioning I wasn't
questioning it in the I still like to
explain to people people they don't
understand
why you guys have to do what you have to
do I understand it I do my tires are
shit to be they
have but like I said I'm not lying to
you that
their it's not like it's not like a
criminal it's I know you're not lying to
me I just I try to be totally honest
with people and not you know I try not
to screw people just because people
think we're police we don't know to do
that because he's got to go down there
and I you know I'll please
this yeah no
I 600 B Brook doing a transport to their
headquarters soon as they're clear
they'll come over to help
you
just take
still
turn
603 she the
paper
for
we'll see we're going to keep our
fin they
call so where's my car going to be
taken so you'll be able to pick it up
you'll be able to pick it up tomorrow be
[Music]
like I don't know how exactly they they
make the prices
but as long as long as you're picking it
up just pick it up as soon as you can
which is 15 hours from the time of their
arrest
so and when can I get these off as soon
as we get back I'll take them off I
can't take them off from the car
it just
hurts am I putting my hands the wrong
way you keep your hands how do I how do
I keep my hands if if you keep them
together they're not I I I promise you
they're they're tight but it's like if
you if you hold my hands keep your hand
keep your hands keep your hands like
like this way there you go like you keep
it that way that way yeah that's the way
the goes oh okay
okay
um and what happens if uh nobody answers
well well let's I'll just stay the night
I'm then you would have to you would
have to stay here for we don't want that
happen you have to stay here for like
you have to stay here for like 16 hours
and we don't want that that so um
usually there's just a very low chance
that anyone we'll get get we'll get
someone to answer we'll give you your
phone we'll let someone you call it
could be anybody it it doesn't have to
be family it could be anybody over the
age of 18 it yeah the only other person
I would call is my son's father
and they could be family friends could
be anybody it's okay it's okay
yeah
be
sick you put all you put all her stuff
back in right yes all your stuff's back
in the car like your tire iron and all
that stuff so we put all spare stuff hey
thanks appreciate it we want you to lose
all that
stuff this is going to be like $10,000
right uh no it's usually not that much
for DUI no are you sure not that I've
seen in the past 10,000 fines and stuff
10,000,000 I don't really see $10,000 Oh
I thought that was like standard for the
first like I said we don't it's all up
to the court so it all depends on what
happens what theen going to be I know I
know I know I'm just I'm just anxious no
I get
it Daniel do you understand that this is
and I'm sure that my partner explained
that this is just this is a ticket right
it's not criminal I don't it doesn't go
on your record like it's not like a it
doesn't go on your record like like for
example like if you did like if you
committed some if you stole something
right that's a criminal offense right
that's a 2C a charge until you would go
get a complaint that says hey you're
either going to jail or you're getting
released that doesn't happen here so
like you're go these tickets go in the
same this charge goes on the same ticket
as if you got a speeding ticket no way
yeah I swear to God
it comes it goes in the same thing as a
speeding ticket I shouldn't have done
this this is
stupid look people make mistakes right
it happens I just wanted to does it make
you a bad person I get you I understand
people make mistakes it's not a big deal
all right I haven't had a night out you
hurt yourself and didn't hurt anybody
else
months I didn't need to I understand a
lot of people a lot of people do not
mean to and we don't take that
personal
I just want to talk to my dad we'll let
you talk to your dad is he live in
Manville
okay we'll we'll let you call
someone I don't know if anyone's going
to answer right now we we could
try
body I got someone to
watch fa do you still live live
somewhere else now no I live you were
just going back to your grandparents my
grandparents watch my son when I want to
do
things
right right
goodbye
how far are we going from you uh it's
only about 5 minutes
okay you want that window open
please
thank
you
hter
87.0
right
for
92 over
four
for